[Applaudissements]
jeux de seconde on peut faire ça vite
fait juste appeler mon voisin c'est un
dégât des eaux ça dure depuis un an
c'est un an ferme et après sinon règle
pas les trucs tu te tue pour ici de
sortir de ça c'est mieux plus votre
voiture c'est monsieur goulard quoi
c'est un vrai monsieur goulard ouais
c'est vraiment mon voisin c'est vrai
tout est vrai allô allô oui monsieur
goulard oui bonjour monsieur couleurs
julien courbet à l'appareil de lancer
l'émission sans aucun doute est-ce que
je vous dérange pas du tout non non rien
que monsieur goulard je suis navré de
vous déranger mais je vous appelle à
propos du dégât des eaux que vous auriez
provoquer chez chez monsieur combal qui
doit être votre voisin non non non je
vous arrête tout de suite et pas du tout
moi c'est vous parlez de monsieur combal
oui de campagne
maintenant ça ne vient pas de chez moi
on a déjà vu servir de sa vie qui prend
des bains avec moctar toute la journée
j'aimerais que j'ai rien fait sur ses
meilleurs appuis donc est ce que vous
avez à dire à ce monsieur pour moi parce
que ça change tout non c'est une fois
par semaine avec moctar c'est tout c'est
le vendredi on fit en mairie par son moi
pendant que vous tient monsieur courbet
j'ai pas mal de réclamations parce que
j'allais vous contacter justement toute
la nuit
l'interphone qui sommes si on se dirait
que moi je n'en peux plus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le bail n'est pas à son nom c'est un
certain cyril h qui paye l'appartement
look ce monsieur parler d'un petit peu
du propriétaire qui peut en secrète et
le bain c'est un défilé en défilé il ya
beaucoup moi je suis en direct à la wii
c'est à dire est que monsieur fait
attention à sa longue dit toute la
france va savoir qu'il adultes dans le
xviiie à 123,6 jeu c'est vouloir d'eads
et merci merci